hidden deep in the Amazon rainforest far
away from civilization lies a mysterious
City but unlike an old Aztec or Inca
settlement of South America this city is
a lot newer and holds a much stranger
past built in the heart of Brazil in
1928 the city was built to be a modern
day Utopia it had a state-of-the-art
hospital a dancing Hall a cinema and
rows of perfect newly built houses the
city even had its own golf course and
Tennis Court from the outside it looked
like heaven on Earth like the kind of
real estate development that would sell
out in seconds but here's the funny
thing none of the houses in the city
were on sale none of them were even for
rents instead the city was home to
thousands of Brazilian workers who lived
in these houses for free the workers
that lived there had good salaries great
health care and lots of entertainment it
was a true socialist Paradise For the
Working Man especially by Brazilian
Sinners at that time where workers were
often overworked and underpaid but not
everything in the city was as perfect as
it seemed and just a few years after its
construction it looked like this
buildings and houses were looted most of
the people have fled the city and
everything else was engulfed by the
jungle this man made Utopia one of
Brazil's most promising cities had
turned into an abandoned Ghost Town
something really bad had happened here
and what's even weirder is that the
Socialist Paradise wasn't built by local
Brazilians no this socialist Paradise
was built by one of America's richest
capitalists Henry Ford founder of the
Ford Motor Company Henry Ford was the
Elon Musk of the 20th century a very
eccentric entrepreneur and billionaire
with grand Visions for the future so
Henry Ford built this Utopia in the
middle of Brazil and named the city The
Only Name that would make sense Ford
landia was started out as Henry Force
utopian dream descended into a nightmare
filled with chaos violence looting and
the eventual abandonment of forlania but
why my name is Jake Tran I make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more and
this is fordlandia Henry Ford's failed
jungle Utopia
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do you like free stuff well you can get
up to 12 free stocks value up to 30 600
when you sign up for Weeble with the
link below there's no catch all you have
to do is open an account deposit as
little as one dollar and that is it
you'll get up to 12 free stocks value up
to 30 600 deposited straight into your
accounts and yes once the stocks have
settled in your accounts you can sell
them use that money to buy other
software even withdraw the money so you
might as well pause the video and click
the link below to claim your free stocks
now because this promotion is definitely
not gonna last forever signing up is
super fast and easy all you have to do
is fill out some basic information
deposit some money and you're done the
first two shares you get when you open
your account will be valued up to 300
each and the next four to ten shares you
get after you deposit some money in your
account would be valued up to three
thousand dollars each we are going into
a recession right now so you're gonna
wanna make sure you have everything set
up and ready to go so that you can buy
if and when everything crashes and
Weeble is the app to do it it's a really
great commission free stock trading app
that was ranked the best investment app
in 2021 by benzinga and it has a 4.5
star rating From Nerd wallet so what are
you waiting for get your 12 free stocks
battery up to 30 600 right now by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to Weeble for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
during a visit to a slaughterhouse Henry
Ford noticed how the workers would
process whole animals while moving them
down a line it was a very basic version
of a highly efficient production line
and that's when it hit him he could do
the same thing in his car factories
instead of having his workers build one
car at a time his cars would move from
one station to another while different
groups of workers would do just one job
on each car Ford immediately put this
assembly idea into action and by 1905
his factories were producing 25 cars a
day it was an absolute revolution in
efficiency so it didn't come as a
surprise that by 1914 Ford had a
whopping 48 share of the U.S automobile
market and only four years later half of
the cars on American streets were Model
T's he was now the Undisputed King of
the car industry and one of the richest
men in the world with a net worth of
around 1.2 billion dollars or around 200
billion dollars in today's money but one
thing still bothered him Ford's supply
chain wasn't perfect his company was
already producing its own engines and
transmissions and pretty much every
other part came from forward operated
businesses but one crew social part in
the supply chain was still missing
rubber for the tires at the time most of
the rubber and Ford's tires came from
plantations somewhere in Asia but that
left the company dependent on some
outside business to consistently Supply
rubber at high prices and for Ford this
was unacceptable he wanted his own
reliable source of cheap rubber in other
words like the other great monopolists
of his time he wanted to vertically
integrate so he set his eyes on Brazil's
Amazon rainforest the home of the rubber
tree
foreign
making rubber for car tires meant
cutting holes into rubber trees and
collecting their sap in buckets this sap
is called latex once collected the latex
is mixed with a bunch of chemicals and
left to dry and eventually form solid
rubber to Henry Ford the process seemed
pretty simple and he was confident his
company would figure out a way to make
it themselves so in 1927 Ford acquired
two and a half million acres of land
next to the tapa hose one of the largest
rivers in the Amazon it was a huge piece
of land nearly the size of Jamaica
Ford's official goal was to build a
cheap source of rubber to produce his
tires but secretly he had an even bigger
Vision he wanted to build the ideal city
a true American Utopia in the heart of
Brazil's jungle the place where workers
would live work and enjoy a happy life
they would have great salaries the best
Healthcare entertainment and even access
to their very own Golf Course
it would be a proletariat Paradise
unlike anything the world had seen
before
and Ford already had the perfect name
for his Utopia
fordlandia
it would be his next Masterpiece a real
Legacy he would leave behind and the
Brazilians they were ecstatic they
thought Ford was the best guy to uplift
Brazil's struggling economy so people
could enjoy a better way of life
so in 1928 the first teams of workers
arrived on Ford's Land by boat Ford had
hired mostly Brazilians to help clear
the forest to plant rubber trees and
just one year later there were around 1
300 local workers on his payroll but it
wasn't long before trouble would appear
the workers were struggling with the
intense heat of the Jungle the working
conditions and tropical diseases by the
end of the following year 90 people had
already died and hundreds were falling
sick here was Henry Ford two years and
one million dollars down after starting
work on fordlandia with nothing to show
for it but Henry Ford just couldn't give
up and ships continued traveling back
and forth from the U.S to the Brazilian
jungle carrying everything they needed
to build an industrial city from scratch
around 1930 most of the forest was
cleared the rubber trees were planted
and fordlandia began to look like a
small American Town workers and their
families had neat small homes while the
American managers had fancy villas with
Gardens and Verandas there was a first
class Hospital a dancing Hall a cinema
and even a public pool
despite the bumpy start Ford's Vision
was slowly beginning to take shape by
the end of 1930 everything seemed to be
going well but more trouble was brewing
on the horizon
Henry Ford was undoubtedly a brilliant
businessman and innovator he knew
everything there was to know about
engines and making money but
unfortunately he had absolutely no idea
how to plant rubber trees in his mind he
could just steamroll the forest plant
his rubber trees and have the material
ready to go a moment later just like
with this car assembly line Ford
believed more was always better so he
followed a simple plan the more rubber
trees I plant the more rubber I'll get
and the more tires I can produce sounds
reasonable right
to make sure he got the most out of the
land he bought he decided to plant the
rubber trees extremely close together
even though the locals warned him
otherwise
big mistake instead of maximizing his
profits he created the perfect
environment for pests like caterpillars
to thrive unfortunately these
caterpillars also destroyed a lot of his
rubber trees and because the trees were
planted so close together nothing could
stop the caterpillar infestation from
jumping from One Tree to the next and
spreading through his Plantation like a
wildfire but that wasn't all in true
colonizer fashion instead of listening
to any advice the locals offered in
respecting their culture Ford decided to
completely steamroll everything about
the culture of his Brazilian workers
Ford wanted to instill what he thought
was the ideal life for them he expected
them to live clean lives that meant no
unhealthy food no alcohol and no lazy
attitudes not exactly what the Brazilian
workers were used to they liked their
big hearty meals a siesta during the day
and a beer or two in the afternoon but
Henry Ford ended all of that first he
put all his workers on the exact die
oatmeal for breakfast and rice with
bread for dinner it was cheap simple and
in his mind healthy then to make matters
worse he decided to ban all alcohol from
fordlandia that was unacceptable how can
you enjoy life if you can't even have a
little drink in the evening immediately
some of his workers simply walked off
site and never came back
and by December 1930 Ford's remaining
workers decided they had finally had
enough they were fed up with the strict
working conditions they hated the food
they were forced to eat and they really
hated that they couldn't even have a sip
of alcohol after A Hard Day's work but
the last straw that was when the workers
were told that they would now have to
pay for their boring tasteless meals out
of their own Pockets that was it the
animal farms had had enough and that's
when all hell broke loose angry and
frustrated the workers destroyed the
dining hall their working equipment and
generators that provided the city with
electricity most of the rest of
fordlandia was then looted the American
managers were so scared of the violence
that they fled into the forest never to
be seen again at the end of the riot
only a few hundred workers decided to
stay and work all the others had taken
their Loot and left it almost marked the
end of Ford's Utopia but Henry Ford was
not a man who gave up easily so we sent
a new manager to fordlandia to try to
turn things around the new manager
started projects to pave the roads
finish the city's Housing Development
and connect fordlandia to other cities
and towns in the area he also built an
entertainment center that played
Hollywood movies and held dances the
health and education facilities were
also improved it was the first time for
landia had actually come close to Henry
Ford's original vision
but Ford still had one big problem they
weren't producing any rubber most of the
trees were either getting eaten by bugs
or were falling prey to destructive
plant diseases and none of the Americans
wanted to listen to the Brazilians
telling them the Amazon ecosystem Works
differently from what they expected by
the end of World War II Henry Ford was
in poor health so his grandson Henry
Ford II took over the company he
immediately realized fordlandia was more
trouble than it's worth so he sold the
land back to the Brazilian government
for a fraction of what it had originally
cost his grandfather the fordlandia
dream had officially come to an end in
response most of the city's American
population packed their bags and
disappeared
foreign
[Music]
over the years Henry Ford invested about
20 million dollars into his Utopia
that's about 400 million dollars in
today's money and not a single drop of
rubber ever made it to his American Car
factories But the saddest part is that
they could have made it work Ford had
the money the technology and the
Machinery all he had to do was listen to
the Brazilian locals who offered their
advice on everything from how to plant
his rubber trees to how to treat the
workers if he had just swallowed some of
his pride fordlandia may have been one
of the most modern successful cities the
world had ever seen instead fordlandia's
buildings and Machinery were looted
again and most of the Brazilian workers
moved back to their hometowns but in the
past decade Portlandia made a bit of a
comeback the abandoned city was
mentioned again and again in the news
documentaries and even in music
so more and more Brazilian people who
were looking for a new place to live
went to fordlandia and moved into one of
the rent-free houses
they didn't care that big parts of the
city had fallen apart they didn't care
about the city's strange history they
just wanted a quiet place to live and
enjoy their lives today about 3 000
people enjoy peaceful lives in
fordlandia in a way that would make
Henry Ford turn in his grave
fordlandia was one of the most ambitious
projects any American had ever attempted
in the 20th century even though it ended
in disaster at least Henry Ford had some
good intentions unlike some of the other
projects America has taken on over the
years like the CIA black site program
for example during America's war on
terror the CIA basically used secret
prisons all around the world to detain
suspects even though many of the men and
women who ended up there were totally
innocent of course that didn't stop the
CIA from arresting or kidnapping them on
mere suspicions kidnapping them to
Secret locations and putting them
through some of the most violent
sadistic enhanced interrogation
techniques you can imagine the things
those CIA officers did is sicker than
anything we've ever put out on this
channel before but we both know a video
that goes into CIA black sites and their
enhanced interrogation Styles would get
demonetized by YouTube in a heartbeat
that's why we've released it as a
full-length private documentary that's
only a available to members of this
Channel all you have to do to get access
to this exclusive documentary right now
along with other feature-length videos
we've already published like MK Ultra
Monsanto F3 jepstein and roots of Terror
in the Middle East is click that join
button below
people pay tens of thousands of dollars
every semester to attend University and
they still don't know how the world
really works but when you become a
member you'll get access to all this
Insider info for only five dollars a
month and there's a refund policy unlike
most YouTube memberships if you join and
you don't think it's worth it email us
within your first month of joining and
we will personally refund you for your
first month after your first month there
is no refund so scroll down and click
that join button now
[Music]
I found this story super fasting so let
me know what you guys thought in the
comments below and if you're new here
this is one of the biggest channels on
YouTube for documentaries on money power
war and crime so if you enjoyed this
video click that subscribe button below
because we make multiple videos just
like this one every single week for free
so if you enjoyed this one you're
definitely going to enjoy the other ones
you can follow me on Instagram jaketran
but that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one